i mean i've lost 25 pounds why am i
gonna
look and i didn't do it on purpose it's
just that food
became disgusting to me wendy williams
is back for season 12 of the wendy
williams show and she's rocking
a whole new look how you doing the 56
year old tv personality revealed she's
doing
freaking great on her talk shows monday
premiere
in fact she says she's down to her
lowest weight since
high school after dropping a whopping 25
pounds during quarantine
you know i was cooking at first and it
was all good i'm shoveling
stuff in my mouth i'm going out to eat
everything from hot dogs to lobster you
know king crab legs
all that stuff but then it became
like i'm done with food
oh girl not me feel free to send those
hot dogs
and king crab legs to 7 31.
anyway wendy added that when she went in
for a colonoscopy
tmi oops they checked her weight and
she said she was shocked i haven't
weighed this little since
high school uh-huh
yeah so i feel really
good but i'm just alone
in my romance oh well don't you worry
because he might be watching right now
of course wendy and her longtime hubby
kevin hunter split
last year since getting divorced you
know
i'm getting used to life as a single
woman again you know i was married for
you know i was involved with him for
over 25 years
and in april the daytime talk show host
opened up to e.t
about her life in quarantine i'm a
recluse
by nature so being in the house is not a
big thing for me i'm surrounded by
all my good stuff and there's good food
got my cats she also dished on her
weight loss
i'll wake up and then i'll eat a little
something
i'm not eating like i am down i don't
know whether you can see but i'm
i can see so you're gonna come out of
quarantine ready
she's a fool who's eating herself to
fatness during quarantine
because when quarantine is over you got
to get back on the hunt if you're a
single woman